[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue pour cette émission
spéciale Paris sacrée spring ce grand
rendez-vous de l'innovation cette tenue
cette année ici même à HEC c'était le
premier juin et le lendemain il y a eu
les circuits de l'innovation une
occasion rare de découvrir les
laboratoires et les centres de recherche
et de développement des grands groupes
du territoire deux jours de rencontres
entre présentiel et digital près de 100
exposants dont 50 startups qui étaient
répartis au sein de 6 villages
thématiques nous allons vous faire
revivre cette sixième édition avec pour
commencer un tour dans le bus autonome
de la RATP puis nous allons vous ouvrir
les portes de vos contrôles
d'organisation internationale qui
réfléchit à l'aviation de demain une
aviation plus durable vous allez
entendre le directeur technique et
innovation de Saint-Gobain sponsor du
stand green tech ou encore la présidente
d'Ipsen groupe bio pharmaceutique
mondial fidèle partenaire de l'événement
il nous explique pourquoi Paris Saclay
Spring est important pour eux pour le
groupe et pour l'innovation et enfin
notre agenda ce sera à la fin de cette
émission
[Musique]
c'est le meilleur de l'innovation et ce
dans tous les domaines dont la mobilité
je vous emmène dans un bus autonome ce
bus 100% électrique roule sur 6 km sur
le plateau de Saclay c'est vraiment une
expérience unique en son genre en Europe
le projet a été lancé en 2020 par le
Groupe RATP sur la ligne 393 tout de
suite les explications de Sarah Askri
elle est directrice marketing
[Musique]
le bus autonome c'est un projet qui a
démarré en 2020 jusqu'en 2022 sur la
ligne 393 l'objectif c'est que le Groupe
RATP continue améliore cette
expérimentation sur la ligne 910
le territoire Paris Saclay on le sait
aujourd'hui que c'est un territoire
d'excellence et on est déjà en fait
acteur de ce territoire puisque à
travers la filière RATP cap Saclay on
est présent sur ce territoire on
exploite 44 lignes de bus depuis août
donc c'est un bus 12 mètres et donc
c'était un bus conventionnel sur lequel
on a rajouté justement une surcouche
autonome donc avec différents capteurs
qui ont été positionnés sur le bus et
qui permettent de comprendre et de
d'appréhender l'ensemble de
l'environnement qui est autour de lui
donc il a des capteurs de sécurité qui
permettent de pouvoir justement ralentir
et garder une distance de sécurité avec
l'ensemble des éléments autour de lui
mais aussi des capteurs de localisation
qui permettent de pouvoir se repérer de
manière centimétrique sur sa voix pour
être sûr d'être toujours sur sa route
lorsqu'il est mis en place dans de la
conduite sur ligne donc notamment sur la
ligne 393
c'est une première en Europe
effectivement il y a différentes
expérimentations qui sont mises en place
dans le monde par contre pour un
opérateur de transport et non un
constructeur c'est une première puisque
on met justement en place pour du
service voyageur sur une ligne
commerciale qui est la ligne 393 où on
en rajoute ce bus en renfort afin de
pouvoir justement
tenir le retour d'expérience des usagers
sur l'attente qui peut y avoir d'un bus
autonome
gros RATP souhaite améliorer cette
expérimentation bus autonome sur le
plateau de Saclay avec notamment la
ligne 8010 l'objectif c'est d'offrir aux
voyageurs une partie du service en
autonome pour les Jeux Olympiques en 204
[Applaudissements]
après les mobilités la Green tech
Saint-Gobain est un groupe leader dans
la construction durable nous avons
rencontré Stéphane Patrick le directeur
technique et innovation de Saint-Gobain
distribution bâtiment France il nous
explique pourquoi son groupe a accepté
d'être sponsor du stand green tech à
Paris sacré spring
Saint-Gobain et le leader de la
construction durable Saint-Gobain
conçoit développe et produit des
services pour les marchés de l'habitat
et de l'industrie pour la construction
neuve et rénovation
c'est développement nécessite des
innovations importantes
l'objectif dans lequel Saint-Gobain
s'inscrit à horizon 2050 à 0 carbone est
un élément important et nécessite une
application très forte en 2022 nous
avons investi 400 millions d'euros pour
l'innovation
nous sommes aujourd'hui au Paris spring
pour justement nous connecter aussi et
développer des connexions avec des
petites structures des startups qui
développent des innovations les détecter
et pouvoir aussi les intégrer dans notre
processus d'innovation et accélérer nos
développements pour atteindre cet
objectif 0 carbone 2050 non merci Paris
Saclay nous avoir impliqué dans cet
événement et nous avons au cours de
cette journée plus rencontrer différents
acteurs très intéressants très motivés
petits structure très opérationnelle
avec des idées très intéressantes et
pointues que nous pourrions intégrer
dans nos développements et on a pu aussi
partager les innovations sur lesquelles
on travaille actuellement et les
projeter dans leur travaux donc nous
remercions l'ensemble de l'organisation
et avons eu beaucoup d'intérêt de
participer à cet événement international
avec beaucoup d'acteurs beaucoup de
petits structures et beaucoup aussi de
mécènes et d'intervenants et
d'industriels intéressés par cette
connexion la connexion avec les petites
structures est clés et accélère le
développement des innovations dans les
grandes structures c'est pour ça aussi
pour nous c'est très important d'être en
relation et aussi facilite le
développement
autre temps fort de Paris Saclay spring
les circuits de l'innovation l'occasion
de pénétrer dans le sein des saints les
laboratoires les centres de recherche et
de développement des grands groupes du
territoire je vous propose de découvrir
euro contrôle une organisation
internationale qui soutient l'aviation
européenne ces chercheurs ces ingénieurs
travaillent à développer une aviation
soutenable dans le futur rencontre avec
l'un de ses managers Giuseppe mondiales
le hob d'innovation de contrôle situé à
Brétigny-sur-Orge en France mais la
recherche rénovation pour euro contrôle
une organisation
intergouvernementale européenne nous
concentrons nous menons nos activités
dans le contexte de la gestion du trafic
Riom des drones du développement durable
et de l'utilisation de l'intelligence
artificielle dans l'aviation nous sommes
également en centre de simulation de
premier plan en Europe en fait nous
réalisons des activités de simulation
pour permettre aux différents États
membres plus de 40 dans toute l'Europe
de faire des activités de réménagement
de l'espace et rien ou éventuellement
pour la validation de nouveaux concepts
nos activités sont pas européenne vu la
nature de leur contrôle et sont toujours
axés au support compagnies aériennes aux
fournisseurs de services
Orion aéronautique et aux aéroports
pour la résolution de programme pour la
mise en place de notre programme
d'innovation nous opérons au travers en
contact direct qui nous permet d'avoir
accès à des problématiques de ce type de
partenaire et nous serons capables avec
ça de résoudre des problématiques
opérationnels dans un terme très très
court avec la possibilité d'utiliser des
méthodologies nouvelles comme par
exemple l'intelligence artificielle
nous sommes aussi très actifs dans un
domaine tout nouveau on l'appelle new
entrans en anglais c'est à dire les
drones la mobilité urbaine parce que en
gros il y a une demande très élevée et
une demande croissante dans la part des
États d'Européens ou des états quand
même qui font partie de leur contrôle de
mettre en place ce type de nouveau
service ce que dans le futur s'appellera
you space
notre dernier domaine c'est aussi les
études et les modèles que nous
développons dans le contexte de
l'environnement pour avoir effectivement
une aviation soutenable dans le futur
pour cette raison là nous avons
développé des outils et des prototypes
qui permettent de considérer l'impact de
la version dans l'environnement pour
améliorer ce type de impact dans le
futur comme est demandé normalement
aujourd'hui par toute l'Europe
notre collection avec Paris Saclay l'un
des pôles technologique les plus
importantes au monde et fait
effectivement pour pouvoir partager ce
type d'expérience que nous menons ici
dans le monde de l'aviation avec un
monde absolument nouveau qui est les
startups qui sont les écoles et une
technologie qui nous permet aussi
d'apprendre par rapport à ce qui est
fait dans un monde qui est complètement
différent dans le monde du transport
ayant de l'aviation
la visite du Centre d'Innovation
aujourd'hui qui fait partie de ce
parcours de visite dans le contexte de
Paris Saclay spring 2023 est une
occasion parfaite pour montrer aux gens
qui ne connaissent pas ce monde le
transport région la rhétique un autre
monde la recherche l'innovation faite
dans ce domaine dans le même temps pour
nous donner des opportunités de
collaboration et coopérations futures
un circuit de l'innovation qui est aussi
passé par Ipsen ce groupe bio
pharmaceutique mondial est un partenaire
fidèle de Paris Saclay spring il a été
une nouvelle fois sponsor de la filière
santé biotech et les startups du sprint
50 qui ont été retenus dans cette
catégorie et bien ils ont pu être
accompagnés par la présidente du groupe
Catherine George
est une entreprise bio pharmaceutique
internationale qui se focalise sur les
aires thérapeutiques sont l'oncologie
les neurosciences et les maladies rares
Ipsen a une stratégie d'open innovation
c'est à dire une stratégie patronale
avec des startups pour avoir un
portefeuille large dans le domaine
d'intérêt c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons un partenariat de longue date
avec le sprint Paris Saclay
Ipsen est une entreprise avec des
racines françaises familiales ce qui
nous permet à des développements long
terme et des stratégies long terme nous
sommes implantés en France dans les
territoires de l'Île-de-France mais
aussi à Dreux et dans le sud de la
France assigne avec des usines nous
avons donc une présence dans
l'écosystème qui est riche et nous
sommes très engagés avec l'innovation en
santé au travers de partenariats avec
France Biotech sur le mentorat sur le
Spring Paris-Saclay en terme
d'innovation locale mais aussi au
travers de collaborations avec des
startups françaises qui sont présentes
au sein de notre portefeuille
le cadre du partenariat avec le sprint
Paris Saclay nous avons eu l'opportunité
aujourd'hui de rencontrer 6 des
finalistes du Spring 50 nous avons
organisé une table ronde avec les
directeurs de l'innovation chez Epson
pour discuter du partenariat en
entreprise des attentes des industriels
et comment on pouvait collaborer de
façon complémentaire entre start-up et
grands groupes itsen a donc participé au
jury sprint 50 dans le cadre de Lewarde
pour la santé des biotech on a été ravi
d'être président du jury pour la
deuxième année consécutive on a été ravi
de remettre un prix à la start-up si
génétique ce qui a gagné le prix du du
jury c'est une start-up qui développe
des biopsie liquides et avec une
technologie particulière et nous pensons
que c'est une amélioration importante au
service des patients
[Musique]
place maintenant à notre agenda on
commence avec le 23 juin rendez-vous au
quartier de l'École polytechnique pour
la pose de la première pierre de la
déchetterie ressourcerie le lendemain le
24 juin 50 ans en Yvelines ne vous
invite au Golf National pour la journée
olympique à j-400 de la première épreuve
accueilli sur le territoire venez vivre
une journée exceptionnelle sur ce futur
site olympique le 28 juin la SAT Paris
sacrée vous propose un atelier sur la
cartographie de la filière sécurité
défense cybersécurité à Paris Saclay
c'est au playground enfin le premier
juin ne ratez pas le TEDx Saclay sur le
thème cercle et liberté c'est au Palais
des Congrès à Massy et c'est la fin de
cette émission je vous retrouve avec
plaisir pour un nouveau numéro de
paris-saclet TV d'ici là restez informés
sur le site
eparé saclay.fr à très bientôt
[Musique]